Gonzalo was a pretty interesting
character he was um he was
very he was polarizing for sure uh
people either hated him or they loved
him um you know you go on social media
um because I share Tucker's story on my
um Twitter feed and uh you know half the
people are like yeah rest in peace and
the other half the people are rest in
pissed because they didn't like him um
so he had some pretty strong opinions
that uh hurt some people's feelings
obviously but um you can't deny that he
was um he was uh somebody that got
eyeballs you know he got people's
attention I saw him as a filmmaker and I
came across this stuff on Coach redel
first so he was um he was putting out
these
videos kind of similar in the vein of
what I talk about a lot of the videos
were so let me just back up a bit I've
I've consumed a lot of books in Evo pych
and even in the red pill space I've
written my own obvious viously
summarizing my experiences but there
wasn't a lot of videos that I would
watch just because I found them drony
and boring and
uncompelling and uh just too long and
full of basically um his coach red
pill videos I would recommend people go
back and look at his
archive I know that there's um
patreon um that he had for years that
has loads and video loads of videos out
there I really hope his um
uh widowed Wife and Kids you know more
so his kids get uh whatever revenues are
still coming from that but somebody
should take his um Archive of videos
everything and put it out on uh the
internet um because there's some good
stuff there it was it was so good in
fact that um I was envious of the way
that he would edit his videos um because
again you know he was a filmmaker he was
really good at telling stories he was
really good at getting ideas out
distilling things they weren't always
complete there was a few um you there's
a few that I came across you know for
example um one that comes to mind he was
talking about daddy issues you know and
he was like uh basically 10 12 minute
video stay away from him with daddy
issues they're always Bad News Bears uh
here's a personal story about a girl
that I dated with daddy issues and this
is what happened and this is why I think
you should stay away from daddy issues
women but there was a level of things
that I sometimes you know found missing
which I love to have conversations with
them on um so in that regard there was
the um you know there's a notion of okay
well there's a woman that could have you
know uh a father in her life but still
have daddy issues in the sense that um
she wouldn't follow his boundaries you
know for example which is something that
I talked about in the red flag chapter
of my book um and a woman could have a
dad in her life so have a relationship
with him see him at family events and
all that sort of stuff but have um no
respect for his boundaries or his
guidance and stuff like like that and I
think that's something that um is often
missed but overall videos are great um
many many topics covered there they're
still you know they're Evergreen um you
can watch them today and be like Yep
this is still true this is still
something that would be useful I was I
was sort of you know perusing some of
the live chat and it's going a little
bit crazy right now because I forgot to
turn it on for members but um you know
some people were like you know he
unplugged me for making bad mistakes I
almost married a 304 um you know this
guy um you know was the father like I
never had and I think that he played
that role for a lot of dudes I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out